uh Joe Biden has cured cancer ladies and
gentlemen we have this from the
post-millennial Joe Biden breaking he
claims we ended cancer as we know it the
real story because I'm not here to bury
the lead or manipulate you is that Biden
mumbled what sounded like we ended
cancer as we know it seemingly on
accident and I just find it kind of sad
and humorous but here I'm so glad I
donated money to him oh my god let's
play the clip yeah and fed everything at
all Joe what would you do
I said I'd cure cancer they looked at me
like why cancer because no one thinks we
can
that's why and we can't yeah that's why
I mean and the cancer as we know it
the clip it's a little late for Bo huh
here's I I got I gotta I gotta say to
the post millennial post millennial do
not clip audio do not clip the audio
right after a word is spoken while he's
still speaking because that diminishes
the the veracity of making this claim
for all we know he said we added cancer
as we know what I mean to say is we can
end cancer reason but you cut him off
and now we don't know the content but
I'll give you some more context if you
look this up during the campaign the
2020 campaign he explicitly said when
I'm elected we will cure cancer yes he
did yes yeah he did but he but he but if
you look at the whole context it was
like we're not going to stop until we
put enough resources to solve this so it
was out of context the sentence that
sounds crazy and I'm sure that's what
it's a throwback for him by the way I
had this tweet and I think you only
reached out to it all those bio labs in
the Ukraine are for us to come up with a
cure for cancer maybe
and to confirm what you're saying it was
in otumo Iowa June 11 2019 Biden said he
would quote cure cancer the other thing
that I'm really excited about is if it's
Trump Biden as the two candidates it
will be literally impossible to convince
Joe Biden that he's not living in 2020.
literally that's what I wondered about
what he said here I think what he meant
to say was we're gonna cure cancer as we
know it but he said it in the present
tense yes he's done he's okay so this is
not the worst thing he's done there was
the famous story where he kept saying
Libya instead of Syria and it's it's
kind of a big deal if the president
commander-in-chief is speaking to the
armed forces and this he was he was
being at the U.N or whatever but imagine
he goes to a meeting is in Situation
Room he's like we gotta bomb Libya and
they're like are you sure it's like yeah
just just get him out of there just just
do it it's like okay I guess then it's
like breaking news the next day New York
Times U.S declares war on Libyan we're
like why we did that already though
lately France did it for us yeah you
know if he was like instead of saying we
got to send troops and he's talking to
his generals we got to send troops and
he says troops are in the generals will
be like what they're already in there
because he's speaking to the president
you know what's really funny is that
there was a lot of talk like this when
Trump was in office and people in the
lab Democrats were freaking out like
they think Trump's an idiot and I can't
put this guy's Community yeah this guy's
commander-in-chief but I don't think
Republicans have that fear about Biden
because there's really an understanding
that he's not running anything so he's
like saying all these things and
everyone's just like yeah who cares like
we know he's not running the military I
don't I don't 100 that like he's he's he
it's it's never Joe Biden actually
calling his shots yes he's definitely
got handlers that are telling him what
to say he admits it at the podium
constantly that's because they'll get
mad at me they want me to say this he he
tells people all the time and that's
been his career that's why he got the
nomination he was a team player he's a
party hack I agree and disagree I think
it's true he has AIDS and and
hey good news Jack good news Jack
Joe Biden has White House aides who tell
him his staff members what to say and
who to call upon and things like this
and he says they're going to get mad
people assume that means there's like
there's like a CIA Puppet Master pulling
strings when it could just be that Biden
has staff members who get angry when he
asks them for help they give him help
and then he doesn't do what they say it
doesn't mean that he's literally being
told he has to do things I think it's a
combination of the two I think he does
just go with the flow and is told to do
things but then he also just does things
himself and that creates chaos I also
think that in many ways of similar to
Trump because Trump very clearly seemed
to not be a big picture was a big
picture guy and wasn't worried about the
minutia and it seemed very clear it's
like okay I trust you because when
you're running like a trump
organizational Hotel organization you're
not looking at the hotel in Atlanta the
hotel New York you have someone you
trust they're there and you delegate it
so you know that's kind of I'm sure that
was the situation during his presidency
and that's why a lot of went off the
rails because he didn't have a strong
deck of people to staff and then they're
just going rogue yeah bragging about it
I don't know I I don't even think this
Biden is the other Biden you don't look
nothing like the original Biden neither
do you well that's true
look who's talking yeah that's true you
got plastic surgery that's the funniest
thing is that what it is yeah you got
hair plugs for sure I'm pretty sure oh
yeah he's got to live for sure yeah I
mean the old Biden has a much square
face yeah well they they pull your flesh
back you know well I've had that so I
know that but still his cheekbones were
much wider and are you the original Joe
Biden is that what you're trying to tell
us I think he's being portrayed by an
actor right I do I think he's wearing a
mask and he's a mask
did you guys see The Jamie Foxx video no
Jamie Foxx put out a video and he's like
hey guys you know I'm all right and then
everyone started showing these like
celebrity headshot pictures of his face
alongside his cell phone video where
he's pale
and it's really simple it's it's the
it's the it's the width of the camera
lens so you you there's a you Google
this YouTube video camera lens
Distortion face and you can see a guy's
face changing Shades I gotta ask
Roseanne I gotta say cloned it let me
ask you this Roseanne if you've you've
you're been in Hollywood for decades if
you're gonna have an actor who's going
to play Joe Biden when you have an actor
who knows how to deliver the lines
well they told him to act like he's got
the Alzheimer's why would she say that
what you want an actor who acts like he
doesn't have the elsewhere no because
they're it's all a show it's all a show
for the American people well that was a
bit too much now that's a sitcom I would
like that's true yeah that's true
because people have to see how it works
look at it's The Sopranos why is nobody
saying what's going on is it's the Noose
Sopranos with the Biden family I think
you should bring back the Golden Girls
and have them but half of all have
Alzheimer's here's what I think is funny
when it comes to the they show a picture
of Biden next to an older picture of
mine it says by Dan or whatever and
they're like by Dan versus Biden like
like Biden right now is actually by Dan
they call them and it's and it's like
they point to his ears
right but I'm like okay dude he got a
facelift yeah
right right and so people like part of
my ears is different and they're like
why is his face a different shape
different camera lens man like there's a
bunch of different photos of different
people here they do see the one he was
scratched in the back of his head and
The Mask
it's his loose old skin now it was way
too much skin I think it's Jim Carrey
planning it could be Jim Carrey nobody
could fall up this thing no no no no no
no it's all righty then it's a Wonder
Years Fred Savage and the other guy
became Marilyn Manson do you know you
ever see that Family Guy episode where
uh Rush Limbaugh was actually uh Rush
Limbaugh was actually Fred Savage yeah
and he's and he's also Michael Moore and
he's like you know after The Wonder
Years acting dried up but he had this
thirst to act so he just became all of
these personalities what about this
conspiracy theory that it was uh Baron
running Trump's Twitter because no like
80 no no seven-year-old senior citizen
could be that much of a great
poster it's got to be this kid
or that uh Steve Bannon is Baron from
the future oh yeah yeah
uh anyway what were we talking about how
someone's acting for Biden uh acting as
Biden because that's why
that's why he speaks like that because
you just can't hit it out of the park so
you've got to pick something that's off
and just go commit to it no come on like
no I'm just Joe Biden got a bunch of
surgery he got plastic surgery got his
hair done it's really disturbing Hillary
he's falling apart he's got plates in
his brain he can barely talk it's like
he's just he's just losing what he's
just a placeholder is that what you
think yeah that that was um what
magazine was it Atlantic oh yeah 2020
election they said time wasn't it with
the no no no no no Atlantic said stay
alive Joe Biden all you need is your
corporeal form yeah they were outright
saying we just need a guy who can get
votes but for four years it was pretty
clear during the Trump presidency that
the president has far less Powers than
we are told and it was a complaint of
his that it's like the government's
running itself and I'm not they're
they're bragging about how they kind of
you know did enruns about him and the
Press was cheering it on like especially
with the like oh what do you mean the
cheering on the idea that for the first
time in my lifetime the president had
his authority rescinded and revoked now
there's there's bad things to that in
terms of what Trump wanted to do like
ending War but the idea the present all
of a sudden was being curtailed I was
like Wow as a first no but I meant
because that's a disruption of our whole
uh constitutional republic but what were
they lying about trying to destroy the
executive branch and bring up you know
was it destroying it or was it just
demonstrating how it really works no
they tried to disrupt the whole balance
of power in our government they said
they said before uh Trump even was
inaugurated they were going to impeach
him yeah now now we have um I did this I
covered this this morning uh Kevin
McCarthy announces a strongly worded
letter to be sent after Rand Paul said a
strongly worded letter a second without
fauchi oh two times the second one oh if
it's a third one three strikes and
nothing happens yeah I told her I
treated I tweeted Iran Paul that he
should ask fauci for a cure for his
impotence because it's insane how these
Republicans uh Chuck Grassley is another
one Chuck Grassley was either ranking a
member of the House of the Senate excuse
me District committee he wrote letters
to the uh doj this is the Trump doj
about Julie swetnik I'm Like This
Woman's lying Brazil in front of
Congress he doesn't get a call returned
writes another letter year later doesn't
get a call return sends out a press
release so the Republicans are bragging
that they can't even get a call return
this is something to be cringing and
embarrassing about instead of telling
your voters it's disgusting so McCarthy
announces a potential that this this may
lead to an impeachment inquiry oh wow
not even an impeachment an inquiry and
to a maybe later click on this link and
send me money that's how it works thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time